temi tutti i pochi capelli verdi ti ho
sempre fatto del bene sanno a mitraglia
così a vita questo continuando a cercare
di scappare la sta tizia sa che cos'è
sta roba
il pin life education ma è ovvio che un
gioco del genere sia sponsorizzato da
happy life tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono vari j
ed oggi siamo tornati sugli under
simulator riaggiornato di brutto voglio
scoprire se ti amo la mano perché hanno
ogni volta aggiungono robert altro a
scuola è cambiata non c'è più il
giardino lunghissimo ci sono m un
cristiano entra a scuola che cosa c'è
nel giardino della scuola un coltello
delle forbici una katana un taglierino e
un cacciavite ben disposti ma è ovvio
c'è questo lo sapeva dove sembra sempre
voglio vederlo infatti quanto pare che
pantaloni sexy come cazzo ho fatto
innamorarmi di uno che esce come un
troglodita un gran figo ma perché la
gente si deve vestire così allora questa
incazzata già si è svegliata male questa
la faccia vedova che incazzata che è il
tipo dietro mi sono fatto delle foto non
posso ma come sospettosa c'è un cortile
interno adesso non fantastico ci hanno
cambiato un sacco di lavora tutti gli
zombie ma perché c'è degli occhiali 3d
deficiente tipo un modo per tirare le
mode
ho trovato a perché c'è ma sono tutti
scheletri oddio no no le modelle di
victoria's secret
non potete magnate qualcosa dio mio non
volevo attivare questa cosa l'ho
sbagliato ma non è il mio telefono
[ __ ] eva penso mi stesse guidando il
mio è il tuo o brutta [ __ ] dove vai
dove che arriviamo a stare
quella tipa delle tette più grosse delle
mie farà innamorare sempre sicuramente
sono la ferma io lo so perché gli uomini
sono tutti porci e allora fuori fuori
ok marco di tezenis le mutandine stronzo
ma tu sei morta rendita lo multicentro
un quando ti capita diosanto una mazza
da baseball
ma come perché a me ha un certo stile
come indie mi piace un sacco alveo a
elvis presley e velici di pigliarsi un
attimo ci di mondizia madonna eccomi qua
fratello portato sta sotto cane eccolo
qua e lo lascio qui posso ecco qui è
riporta la casa è noti e che mi guardi
così titolo impacchettato anche i
postini la madonna che sta roba
se ma posso usarlo ragazzo ci fa una
lama dentro una vabbè per tagliare le
aiuole il club dell'occulto ma c'è chi
si sto per fare il casinò più totale ci
prova poi non so quanta gente ci sia la
dottoressa un po prima di tutto lo trova
sempre ci sarà tiple tetto sì perché per
forza se non ce l'ha ecco salve qui da
chiacchieriamo un secondo voi capire chi
sei non puoi parlare adesso della linea
amica mia cia ci sentiamo alla prossima
forca smembra seriamente cosa ma cosa ma
come ma cos'è sta roba seria vendola
come contenta di essere smembrata serio
perché ha cambiato vestito cioè quando
smembri una persona in genere cambia
vestito ciao chiara vieni passo che ci
stiamo divertendo era quella che bello
tesoro ti offrono questo ecco guarda che
bella ecco qua vedete devono darmi un
premio una borsa di studio solo per come
arredo la la scuola ma che minchia
arrivo io tocco di classe tanta roba il
corso prendimi il torso
ecco qua te grati stanca di avere le
tette piccole a zio favi sempre al torso
giusto che perse
mi piace come cazzo fa sparire il sangue
così cosa sto diventata una filippina
filippina simulator è diventato
soggiorno quando vedranno la scena del
crimine che ci sono tutti i pezzi giu
penseranno che si è tagliata le cose è
che la
e giù e poi si è messo a guardare c'è
giusto ci rimane solo il fatto io sono
tutta sporca però quello è un altro
discorso
dai sole d'oro sono anti pulisci qua
grandissimo a perché devo spogliarmi per
un certo 4 cazzo adoro questo videogame
posso fare il bagno qui fatto i bagni
così non li ho mai visti ct siediti
pulisci cos'è questa cosa e dai
maledizione ma costa esposta la
nuvoletta rimontarci da prassi vado in
giro così purtroppo ragazzi mi son
rivestito lo so lo so che è una tragedia
per tutti voi anche per me però mi sono
dovuto rivestire che non posso andare in
giro nudo ma fermiamoci nati voglio
vedere la gente che se ne accorge posso
pastime fatevi vedere che cazzo succede
stanno uscendo adesso di vendola qua
guarda lì a caso ma come al caso paolo
festa
esci da questa stanza ma edizione cosa
in sé inglobata al banco dio mio sia 6 c
da fa vedi che c'è un torso ridevi
spaventare
ok ti devi spaventare appena le vedi ce
la fai ma perché lago jona c'è un torso
c'è un torso guarda l'ho fatto io lo
vedi in mezzo ai 100.000 fregata bene
vediamo al prossimo giro nuda visto che
sempre se fai il tesoro
no questo non sono è mio e io sono più
bella si permessa di guardarlo lo stesso
anche senza testa lurida [ __ ] a sto
punto ragazzi fate mi gira nudo che così
vedo che crei reaction c'è la gente
soprattutto sempai è l'unico modo per
conquistarlo cioè mio dio ne frega un
cazzo sei passo nudo ovvero tanto state
studiando impegnati a studiare l'occulto
nessuna nota che ci sono due tizi che
stanno vabbè non importa faccio un bel
regalo zio attiva di chiacchierare un po
nicchia come saltato la cavavo voglio
posso fare i complimenti per così bello
e tu mi risponderai grazie ciao
guardale se lì seduto queste scelte poi
dove vai sempre guarda qui che mercanzia
guarda quanto sono gnocco guarda delle
vere zinne per la prima volta nella sua
vita
ma chi si nutra moon avis che tenga la
sindaca
ma che cazzo art broken ma sei scemo
proprio ragazzi a sto punto ha deciso di
far fuori chiunque
intanto sempre mi ha rotto i [ __ ]
quindi va a fan corso titolo prof
[Musica]
cosa qualche a [ __ ]
ma veramente minchia e steven seagal
regga su valle così stati suoi
complimenti a quella questa sbirciate
stai altre tipiche per ragazzi una tipa
che si sta suicidando laggiù anzi e mi
servirebbe attaccarti così ecco perché
madonna vanta brutta questa cosa che fa
ogni volta è la gente non si stupisce ne
frega cazzo alle persone secondo me i
ragazzi quando vedono inizia a
tagliuzzare le persone cece pia male
tutti quanti altro che torto perché in
casa ecco mi sembrava strano non ora
devi morire anche tu eri anche tu
l'altra e continua a guardare non ho non
pregare devi scappare zia il cazzo
successo all'altra
no no no che sta scappando corrie starda
sono morti tutti ma c'è ancora l'altra è
tanto che cazzo vienna devi morire
ora quella che ballano sotto la panchina
di cazzo è finita quella perfetta
ragazzi fa lezione zio favi stavolta a
stronzone merda vecchia testa lana
ma serio ma come faceva una lama e la
cosa non entrare in cassette ucciderti
prima tu non hai visto niente ciao
infarto [ __ ] ma questa qui erano
già input altro che chuck norris alive
in di superman
[Musica]
ragazzi prova a far fuori qualcuno
mentre sono così perché mi chiami fa
troppo prendere bene ciao
porca merda riuscita sopra la porta via
via via via via via via vedere quanto è
veloce oddio mio vai vai bye bye bye bye
bye vede mi suicido lo ha detto mi
suicido quanto così velocista [ __ ]
no no tav anni tutti i pochi capelli
verdi ti ho sempre fatto del bene sanna
mitra iamm continuano così a vita questo
continuando a cercare di scappare la
satira sa che cos'è sta roba
quanta demenza in una sola scena per
quel cazzo mi suicido la affanculo sono
quasi ti piace mettere giù quelle
svestite brutto fra mon amour due
ragazzi lascio perdere diventa però è
diventato più figo perché hanno fatto un
sacco di cose se ci sapesse giocare a
sto gioco visto che macello perché
finirla impossibile però va beh spero vi
sia piaciuto l'episodio spero grande
attesa in pie divenga un forum con
infront perché fai schifo però ti
atteggi come se fossi di caprio ha
ucciso un poco di gente oddio che cazzo
e questo pur eliminarmi aiuto ma certo
ma cosa adesso si becchi ma è di quelle
denunce per avermi toccato brutto
pervertito di merda bene ragazzo ha
concluso filo episodio è stato a quanto
non sense tanto per cambiare se è vero
che video di sia per tutte cose in
seguito piaciuta sotto momento è un mi
piace ai capace di facebook che come da
tradizione si discute ci vediamo il
prossimo mito e la ragazza